et vous êtes tellement pauvre quand vous
êtes enfant Quincy Jones que vous mangez
des rafies c'est à dire que votre
grand-mère vous cuisine plutôt bien
d'ailleurs des rafies
[Applaudissements]
très heureux de vous avoir avec nous ce
soir
[Musique]
voilà Queen c'est Jones arrangé écrit
produit tous ces morceaux et bien
d'autres 100 millions d'albums vendus
Queen si Jones ou comment un gamin des
faubourgs les plus misérables de Chicago
et devenu l'un des plus grands
compositeurs arrangeurs producteur de
musique au monde
voilà Queen si par Quincy Jones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alors on va parler on va parler du
bouquin qui est magnifique et dit c'est
un bonheur de rencontrer Quincy non
on se connaît depuis de très nombreuses
années Quincy m'a connu tout petit tout
petit quand il travaillait
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
Quincy lui sont souvent mais c'est
marrer c'est quand j'ai démarré que le
groupe Les Chaussettes Noires et il
enregistrait la musique du film avec
Paul Newman il y avait Armstrong et
c'était monsieur déjà qui faisait les
arrangements
étaient les témoins de 5 de mariages
c'est sûr que les mariages des libertés
ça donne des occasions de se retrouver
ça vous fait plaisir que c'est de voir
Quincy Jones
vraiment vraiment alors il a écrit un
bouquin qui commence très mal ça
commence dans les hivers du Kentucky il
fait très froid vous dites un froid
mordant impression de gelée de
l'Intérieur impression qu'on aura plus
jamais chaud et vous êtes tellement
pauvre quand vous êtes enfant Quincy
Jones que vous mangez des RAF fris
c'est-à-dire que votre grand-mère vous
cuisine plutôt bien d'ailleurs des
rafies
en ce moment ça serait quand même
beaucoup plus chiant alors votre mère
est malade ça a été vraiment un problème
vraiment pour vous on le voit en lisant
le bouquin toute votre vie vous avez
vécu avec ce poids elle s'en va un jour
on vous dit qu'elle revient tard à
bientôt le problème c'est que ce bientôt
allait durer des années et il y a une
scène extraordinaire dans dans votre
bouquin c'est le jour où les infirmiers
l'emmènent ils lui mettent une camisole
de force elle hurle elle se débat et il
l'emmène quand même alors vous racontez
aussi la visite à l'asile ou votre mère
est enfermée alors au départ elle sourit
vous dites quand on arrive elle sourit
avec son son beau sourire comme quand
elle nous brossait les cheveux ou quand
elle nous mettait nos culottes courtes
et un moment son visage change
complètement et elle se met mise en
colère et elle part dans la rage et pour
un enfant ça doit être terrible ça
sauf que depuis
j'ai appris que bon avec cette démence
précoce elle aurait pu être sauvée si on
l'avait donné un peu plus de vitamine B
c'est tout ce qu'il leur tout ce qu'il
aurait fallu dans les années 30 et 40 on
ne savait pas tout ça alors tout au long
de votre livre comme ça il y a des
réapparitions de votre mère un jour en
61 vous êtes à New York dans un club qui
s'appelle le Birdland qui est vraiment
la Mecque la Mecque du jazz elle
débarque et quand vous entendez dans
l'escalier vous dites il va arriver elle
va faire un scandale et alors un jour
vous avez quand même compris que les
problèmes que vous aviez eu par la suite
avec les femmes votre côté donjon votre
don Juanisme exacerbait Quincy Jones
était dû au problème finalement que vous
aviez connu dans la relation avec votre
mère
la ville de Paris m'a un peu aidé à
régler ses problèmes alors après le
départ de votre mère votre mère vous
emmène chez votre grand-mère et là vous
connaissez le vrai racisme c'est à dire
qu'à l'époque aux États-Unis il y avait
encore il y en a toujours à l'époque il
y avait un vrai gros racisme humiliation
à l'école on vous demandait à vous à
votre frère d'enlever vos chaussures
pour vous gratter la la crasse sous les
pieds alors finalement dans votre paire
revient à vous chercher chez votre
grand-mère vous partez au sud de Chicago
dans un quartier qui est tellement
violent qu'on l'appelle le saut de sang
il y a des bagarres il y a des vols il y
a des gangsters et vous devenez un petit
truand c’est à vous apprenez à vous à
vous défendre qu'une signe Jones et un
jour voilà vous apprenez que dans la
salle des fêtes de l'endroit il y a de
la nourriture qui est stockée ça
s'appelle l'arsenal vous entrez la nuit
par effraction et vous trouvez une
glacière dans laquelle il y a des tartes
au citron meringuées donc il rentre
comme ça la nuit il a vous voyez un
vieux piano qui est là sur une sur une
estrade vous le regardez vous commencez
à pianoter d'un doigt et vous trouvez à
ce moment là la paix pour la première
fois vous vous savez au moment où vous
entendez cette note que que vous générez
en tapant sur le piano vous savez que
c'est votre destin vous dites cette
phrase extraordinaire chaque note
comblée mais vide intérieures j'avais
trouvé en une seconde une nouvelle mère
la musique
effectivement ce moment ma littéralement
sauvé la vie et bien moi pour moi j'ai
eu cette nouvelle mère la musique a été
cette mère bienveillante qui m'a donné
tout l'amour que j'attendais et qui m'a
rendu l'amour que je vous donnais
cette chance ensuite vous installez à
Seattle vous rencontrez Ray Charles sur
quelle époque c'est extraordinaire
Ray Charles avait 16 ans vous vous avez
14 ans et c'est pour vous c'est un
modèle Ray Charles c'est à dire que
malgré sa cécité il se comportait comme
un petit homme il était tout à fait
indépendant malgré son jeune âge 16 ans
et vous vous commencez à le prendre
comme modèle
en effet un modèle parce que moi
j'habitais encore à la maison alors que
Ray Charles avait son propre appartement
il était propriétaire de deux costumes
d'un photographe et de deux petites
amies alors c'était fabuleux il était
parfaitement capable de faire tout ce
qu'il voulait pouvait aller au magasin
tout seul traverser pour feu rouge
rentrer chez lui faire ses achats et
le seul moment où on était plus aveugle
c'est quand lui ou Stevie wonderait une
belle fille à la tout d'un coup il
faisait semblant d'être avec pour être
aidé par les belles femmes
aujourd'hui est encore mon ami le plus
proche au monde alors voilà c'est sur le
piano de Ray Charles ce que vous
travaillez le premier morceau que que
vous avez écrit dans votre vie et là il
y a un épisode assez triste c'est qu'un
jour vous rencontrez là il y en amponne
et vous lui demandez de faire partie de
son orchestre il vous accepte dans
l'orchestre c'est vachement content vous
êtes très jeune et la femme de la Lionel
Hampton arrive et commence à l'engueuler
en disant
appris des choses dont je me souviens
encore à ce jour des choses que je n'ai
compris que 20 ans après les avoir
entendu et c'est probablement la
personne en tout cas sur le plan musical
qui est le plus influencé
avec elle au sujet de Stravinsky mais je
sais pas si c'est vrai
de Stravinsky de Ravel qui avait eu
Bernstein comme élève qui avait refusé
Gershwin elle vous a tout appris à vous
et elle vous a appris surtout que
finalement il n'y avait pas de vrai
création sans contrainte c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne pouvait créer qu'à l'intérieur
d'un cadre défini sinon c'était pas
possible
si on n'a pas de contraintes alors on ne
peut pas avoir de liberté moi je
trouvais ça un peu difficile parce que
j'avais joué dans des boîtes de nuit
au plus enfin mais c'est elle qui était
un véritable géant de la musique elle
m'a dit une chose que je n'oublierai
jamais elle a dit que la musique d'une
personne ne peut pas être plus ou moins
que ce que vaut cette personne notre
enquête humain et ça c'est une bonne
raison d'essayer d'améliorer sa propre
vie en tant qu'être humain
alors en 57 vous êtes de nouveau en
France engagé donc par Nicole Barkley
comme directeur musical arrangeur chef
d'orchestre et vous pouvez enfin écrire
des arrangements pour corne parce que
les États-Unis à l'époque de toute façon
les noirs n'avaient pas le droit
d'écrire les arrangements pour cordes
on est illimité au cuivre donc j'ai
appris énormément de choses grâce à des
Barclay il m'a appris tout pas
simplement la musique d'ailleurs
également la cuisine
voilà donc
il découvre la Jet 7 la Côte d'Azur d'un
seul coup évidemment pour vous c'est
énorme alors ensuite vous raconter en 74
trucs terribles une un anévrisme
sakiforme donc c'est l'artère principale
qui emmène le sang dans l'hémisphère
droit du cerveau qui s'est rompu c'est
l'équivalent de 16 attaques et vous
devez subir à ce moment-là une opération
du du cerveau vous avez une chance sur
100 de vous en sortir et de toute façon
même si vous en sortez vous avez
énormément de risques d'être paralysé
d'être aveugle et là vous raconter cette
scène extraordinaire c'est quand on vous
emmène pour vous pour vous opérer pour
vous passer sur le sur le billard vous
avez le crâne rasé et vos cheveux se
sont mis dans un petit sac en plastique
accroché à la civière au cas où vous
mourrez comme ça on pourra vous remettre
les cheveux pour l'enterrement
tout ira bien parce que malheureusement
vous avez un deuxième année et dans deux
mois vous y repassez et on vous rase une
couleur là c'est ça qui me faisait un
peu peur ça veut dire que vous avez deux
chances une chance sur deux de 2000 dans
Sortir plutôt qu'une chance sur 1000
et alors ça va maintenant
le seul problème c'est que je suis
obligé de faire un régime mais en France
c'est pas facile
c'est pas un régime sans fille au moins
vous avez compris à ce moment-là que on
avait 25000 jours sur terre pour tout
faire et que il fallait en profiter
jusqu'à là de 80 ans on dort pendant 10
jours on travaille 10000 jours il est 10
autres jours c'est pour jouer pour
s'amuser pour tout ce qu'on veut et donc
si on divise sa vie comme ça entre le
sommet le travail et le reste c'est ça
qui vous reste alors c'est ce que je me
dis le pauvre il faut vivre chaque jour
comme si c'était le dernier jour de
votre vie
alors voilà le livre raconte tous les
artistes pour lesquels vous avez
travaillé Quincy évidemment il y a Dina
Washington Frank Sinatra vous rencontrez
à Monaco et qui quelques années plus
tard vous vous rappelle alors vous
pensez qu'il vous a oublié il vous
rappelle pour que vous produisiez son
110 et puis Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson et qui vous avez fait Off The
Wall vous avez fait thriller vous avez
fait bad ensemble thriller 40 millions
d'albums seulement 22 oui c'est vrai
c'est un peu un flop
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce qui est
devenu aujourd'hui
je pense que
disons qu'il a il est passé de du
fantasme à la réalité et vice-versa mais
je crois que on peut pas trop Luscher la
pierre je crois que ce qui lui est
arrivé depuis l'âge de 5 ans tous tout
ce qui m'est arrivé a été
multiplié par 1000 parce que c'est
probablement l'artiste le plus célèbre
en tout cas sur le plan musical c'était
vraiment la star des stars et c'est dur
à gérer si on n'a pas vraiment ils ont
la tête sur les épaules si on n'a pas un
centre spirituel il faut la spiritualité
en soi pour pouvoir garder la tête
froide alors ce qu'on fait en général
dans ce cas là c'est à dire que c'est
l'énergie qui qui vous fait monter
inconsciemment c'est même énergie vous
traîne vers le bas sans qu'on en soit
conscient ça j'ai vu ça des milliers de
fois et j'espère que ça vous arrivera
pas à vous
avez senti un moment vous ça vous est
arrivé ça espèce de vertige comme ça de
vous dire je me sens je me je contrôle
plus je te dire que je si un jour je
vends 40 millions d'albums peut-être
mais donc j'ai le temps
bien alors vous vous avez des problèmes
aussi psychologiques certains moments
vous produisez vous coproduisez la
couleur pourpre avec Steven Spielberg et
à la suite de ça vous êtes victime
Quincy d'une dépression nerveuse
autrement difficile aussi c'est quand
votre fille qui Dada vit avec Tupac et
que Tupac est assassiné aussi très très
beau oui elle était fiancée
être assise à côté de lui dans la
voiture où il s'est fait assassiner
heureusement bah il n'était pas allé
chercher la femme parce qu'elle serait
morte elle aussi
il avait 25 ans c'est incroyable et
quelques mois plus tard big notorious
est assassiné aussi dans dans tout ce
groupe de rappeurs de Los Angeles vous
avez
parmi les premiers à prédire le succès
du rap et l'importance du rap moi je me
souviens on s'est vu pour la première
fois dans une émission en 1989 qui
s'appelait lunettes noires pour nuit
blanche et c'est vrai et vous m'avez dit
bah oui le rap c'est comme le jazz c'est
comme l'Europe ça va tout révolutionner
en étant en 89 bon ça commençait à peine
et vous aviez raison parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça a été une espèce de
déferlante mondiale
j'ai eu ce sentiment parce que j'ai
suivi des tout début du rap
et qui m'a dit une fois dans les dans
les bureaux de FDM il a dit il a demandé
qu'est-ce que pensent les musiciens de
nous et je lui dis mais vous êtes au
fait pas exactement des musiciens des
chanteurs vous êtes dans la tradition
orale africaine ou comme comme les
compteurs de Bangui voilà alors dans
quicksin Jones aujourd'hui vous avez 70
ans et vous êtes en train d'écrire votre
première comédie musicale consacrée à
semis Davis junior vous avez bien connu
vous dites la retraite c'est s'asseoir
et attendent la mort vous êtes après de
prendre votre retraite donc
pas du tout certainement pas beaucoup de
retraite en France en ce moment non ça
risque pas non jamais
à rester vivant dans l'esprit pour que
le corps reste jeune lui aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Quincy Jones est-ce que vous trouvez
normal que vous ne soyez pas parents
avec Indiana Jones
est-ce que vous trouvez normal que le
plus grand rappeur du monde Eminem soit
blanc
le plus grand rappeur du monde et blanc
le meilleur golfeur du monde
tennis woman sont noirs le plus grand
basket voleur et chinois ce sont les
Suisses qui ont l'americascope et
l'Allemagne ne veut pas faire la guerre
et
est-ce que vous trouvez normal que si
Jones qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se
foute de la gueule de Michael Jackson
non
moi je prie pour Michael vraiment je
prie pour lui parce qu'il a beaucoup de
très bonnes choses en lui et
j'espère qu'il s'y retrouvera peut-être
que ça lui prendra du temps peut-être
qu'il faut qu'il se repose un peu est-ce
que vous trouvez normal que beaucoup de
gens aux États-Unis croient qu'Elvis
Presley est toujours vivant
Jones qu'on bande devant un film porno
et qu'on est pas mal devant un film
d'action
ce qui montre un peu la bizarrerie du
monde tout est à l'envers c'est le monde
à l'envers est-ce que vous trouvez
normal que les artistes américains qui
sont contre la guerre d'Irak soit
inscrit sur une liste noire
la démocratie chacun devrait avoir le
droit à ses propres opinions c'est ça le
principe de la démocratie chacun devrait
être libre de ses opinions même si ses
opinions sont dans l'opposition je crois
pas que ce soit juste des blacklistés de
les mettre sur liste noire est-ce que
vous trouvez normal Queen site jaune ce
que je vous pose toutes ces questions à
la con
non non non
madame messieurs et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu